hallo und herzlich willkommen zur
absoluten Premium Folge von ich teste
Höhle der löwenprodukte die Sendung in
der die neuesten Innovationen und Ideen
im deutschen Fernsehen präsentiert
werden wir nehmen in dieser Sendung die
Produkte unter die Lupe und das heute
zum allerletzten Mal auf meinem Kanal
deswegen nehmen wir das heute zum Anlass
uns heute einmal die absoluten
brecherprodukte der letzten Jahre die
Höhle der Löwen anzuschauen welche
Produkte waren am erfolgreichsten haben
wie viel Kohle verdient über die letzten
Jahre haben einen riesenweg nach der
Sendung gehabt wie immer vom wenigsten
bis zum erfolgreich Produkt also bleibt
bis zum Ende dran um nichts zu verpassen
bevor wir uns die ganzen Produkte jetzt
anschauen will ich einmal sagen ich
schaue mir in diesem Video die Umsätze
die Firmengeschichte und die Ideen der
Produkte an ich gehe nicht kritisch auf
irgendwelche Business Entscheidungen ein
es ist aber wichtig sich kritisch mit
Produkten auseinanderzusetzen tut das in
diesem Video werde ich nicht darauf
eingehen Produkt Nummer 1 ist eigentlich
kein Produkt sondern Software und jeder
von euch kennt es angefragt waren 1
Million eur€ für 5% bekommen haben Sie 1
Million für 9,9% von Carsten maschmey
der Deal ist aber geplatzt und das aus
einem ganz besonderen Grund die Firma
ist tatsächlich so schnell gewachsen und
so groß geworden dass sie den Deal
selber abgebrochen haben bevor er
zustande kam die Firma nennt sich to
good to go und ist eine unheimlich gute
App und funktioniert so jeden Tag werden
überall auf der Welt unheimlich viele
Lebensmittel weggeworfen die eigentlich
noch gut und zu gebrauchen sind und
genau diesem Problem nimmt sich to good
to go an einfach anmelden den eigenen
Standort auswählen und nach Ladenschluss
unverkaufte Güter unverkaufte
Lebensmittel zu einem vergünstigten
Preis bekommen und das funktioniert
richtig gut ich habe natürlich Köln
ausgewählt und bekomme jetzt hier
angezeigt wo wir überall sehr
vergünstigt an Lebensmittel kommen
können erst ins Steigenberger Hotel und
dann in den Biomarkt für drei Croissant
vier Brötchen und ein komplettes Set an
frühstückskram haben wir im
Steigenberger Hotel 4,50 € gezahlt die
Brötchen waren noch crunchy und die
Beilagen ganz gut abgestimmt den
Biomarkt haben wir 3,90 € also etwas
weniger gezahlt und diesen ganzen Kram
bekommen bei dem der Ursprungswert mit
12 € beziffert wurde Qual toop und alles
noch sehr gut genießbar für Studenten
Leute die nicht so super viel Kohle
haben Leute die nachhaltiger leben
wollen wen auch immer ist diese App ein
absoluter Traum und was soll ich sagen
ich bin nicht der einzige der das
erkannt hat mittlerweile gibt es zu good
to go in über 14 Ländern hat 18
Millionen Nutzer über 29 Millionen
Speisen wurden gerettet und es wurden
insgesamt über 85 Millionen Euro
eingesammelt das Unternehmen ist mit
über 800 Millionen Euro bewert was
völlig verrückt ist wenn man daran denkt
dass die App einfach mal bei die Höhle
der Löwen war und was soll ich sagen ich
stelle das ja als erstes vor weil es nur
noch krasser wird und bevor wir zum
zweiten Produkt kommen eine kurze
Erinnerung dass ihr mit meiner App savet
beim onlinees Shen warahes Geld sparen
könnt und das in unziligen Shops von
Nike über about you lierando WT es ist
wirklich unglaublich fast in jedem Shop
und das so einfach wie genial App
runterladen meinen Creator Code
auswählen mich und meine Arbeit
unterstützen und Cashback für so gut wie
jeden Online Einkauf erhalten also check
das aus viel Spaß weiter mit dem Video
Produkt Nummer 2 ein weiteres und
letztes Mal Software und ihr kennt es
alle finanzguru ja die sind tatsächlich
mal bei die Höhle der Löwen gewesen
hatten eine Millionen für 10% angefragt
bekommen haben sie die Millionen für 15%
von Carsten maschmeer was ein Firmenwert
von 6,6 Millionen Euro ergibt und das
soll sich als richtig guten Deal
herausstellen über die Jahre nach der
dhdl Ausstrahlung bekommen sie auch
durch meine Hilfe zu mittlerweile 1,5
Millionen Usern und das mit Recht denn
die App ist einfach nur phänomenal ich
habe mehrmals schon dafür geworben
benutzt es aber auch privat deswegen
müssen wir jetzt hier die App von
irgendeinem neuen Account einblenden
weil mein können wir nicht zeigen sonst
seht ihr alle meine Finanzen im Prinzip
hilft euch die Software dabei eure
Finanzen in den Griff zu bekommen zu
sehen was reinkommt was rausgeht
vorausschauen mit seinem Geld umzugehen
und einfach eine bessere Übersicht über
eure Finanzen zu erlangen hört sich an
wie ein placement ist dieses Mal kein
placement aber es ist einfach eine
unheimlich gute App und das haben auch
Investoren erkannt und richtig
ordentlich Kohle in die Firma gebuttert
zuletzt Paypal mit 13 Millionen Euro
Investment und insgesamt wurden jetzt
irgendwie 28 Millionen investiert die
App ist wahrscheinlich irgendwo zwischen
70 und 80 Millionen bewertet aber für
Carsten sch Meer die Gründer und auch
die Nutzer am Ende ist das ein richtig
gutes Ding ein absolutes winning Produkt
und genauso soll es weitergehen das
nächste Produkt nennt sich wly und ist
eine vegane milchalternative angefragt
waren 500.000 € für 8%. das wären 6,25
Millionen Euro gewesen bekommen haben
sie keinen Deal und das sollte sich als
großer Fehler herausstellen denn die
nächsten Jahre nach der Ausstrahlung von
dhdl waren unheimlich erfolgreich ich
glaube die Ausstrahlung war 2018 alleine
dass wir jetzt in 2023 immer noch an die
Produkte kommen ist in den meisten
Fällen ein sehr gutes Zeichen wie gut
das Zeichen war ich muss das hier kurz
ablesen denn es ist wirklich eine Menge
passiert im Jahr der Ausstrahlung soll
der Umsatz bereits im siebenstelligen
Bereich liegen 6 Monate nach der
Ausstrahlung bereits 500.000 l vegane
Milch ausgeliefert 2022 6 Millionen Euro
Umsatz und heute September 23 15
Millionen Liter verkauft über 200
Mitarbeiter und all das ist schön und
gut aber am Ende muss es schmecken es
gibt vier verschiedene Sorten soweit ich
weiß das alles ist aus Erbsen Protein
wie so ein
[Musik]
weintester ja geil man schmeckt dass es
pflanzlich ist aber ich denke das soll
auch so sein Barista Milch die ist
natürlich jetzt eigentlich nicht dafür
gedacht dass sie einfach so normal
getrunken
wird wow wow die schmeckt wie als
hättest Du vorher 5 Minuten Cornflakes
drin eingelegt gehabt also die ist eine
10 von ze wirklich mit Recht ein
absolutes Topprodukt das sich über die
letzten Jahre im Markt etablieren konnte
und genau dafür finde ich steht dhdl
Innovation früh am Zahn der Zeit
Produkte auf den Markt bringen die die
Welt irgendwie ein bisschen besser
machen das tut dieses Produkt
gleichzeitig schmeckt es auch noch gut
besser geht's nicht das nächste Produkt
nennt sich Smart Sleep und könnte
einigen von euch bekannt vorkommen mir
selber hat es Millionen eingebracht
zumindest Millionen Klicks war nämlich
thumbnail der allerersten Folge ich
teste die Hölle der löwenprodukte
angefragt waren 250 000 € für 10 %
bekommen hat der Gründer 1,5 Millionen
für 30%. ja richtig gehört das erste Mal
in der die Hülle der löwengeschichte
haben die Löwen damals den Deal erhöht
und es wurde sich darum gestritten wer
investieren darf der größte Deal zu
diesem Zeitpunkt der die Hülle der
löweneschichte 10 % angefragt oder 250
000 € angefragt am Ende 1,5 Millionen
bekommen das muss schon was heißen und
deswegen nehmen wir das Ding jetzt unter
die Loop der Gründer hat vor der
Ausstrahlung bereits 10 000 Einheiten
davon verkauft gehabt was auch schon
ordentlich ist nach der TV Ausstrahlung
bei dhdl ist dieses Produkt bei QVC dem
Shopping tvsender gelandet da wurde
dieselbe Menge innerhalb von 30 Minuten
verkauft das Produkt kommt also an ist
mittlerweile in unheimlich vielen
Drogeriemärkten sogar zwei Airlines
vertreten früher hat sich eingekauft
gibt Werbebudget und hat dafür Anteile
an dem Unternehmen bekommen das Ding
läuft und wir schauen ob es hält was es
verspricht Smart sleep immune wichtige
Nährstoffe für das Immunsystem Vitamin A
Vitamin B6 Vitamin C Zink Kupfer hört
sich an als wä hier so ziemlich alles
drin was man braucht grundsätzlich fei
ich Nahrungsergänzungsmittel das hier
ist jetzt nicht irgendwie um möglichst
schnell oder möglichst besser und
ausgeglichen zu schlafen sondern das
hier ist um das Immunsystem zu stärken
es riecht sehr gut zitronig orangig
schauen wir mal über die nächsten 7 Tage
ob das hält was es verspricht und mein
Immunsystem besser
wird wow wow sehr sauer gibt ähnlich wie
so ein Gefühl von ingma immer direkt das
Feeling ab von WoW ich werde sofort
[Musik]
gesundt so letzte Ampulle Smart sleep
immune 7 Tage Test gewöhnt an den
Geschmack habe ich mich noch nicht aber
ich fühle mich gut ich fühle mich gut
das Ding ist diese 7 Tage Kuren habe ich
ja gesagt kenne ich schon von omol
andere Anbieter finde ich tatsächlich
super gerade in Zeiten wo viele um ein
herum krank sind und so weiter genau so
eine Zeit ist jetzt ich bin nicht krank
geworden habe ich eine direkte
Auswirkung gemerkt nee nicht unbedingt
muss man da eine direkte Auswirkung
merken wahrscheinlich auch nicht aber
ich finde das gut das schmeckt fein
alles wunderbar cooles Ding und alles
wunderbar das nächste Produkt nennt sich
Little Lunch war mir persönlich kein
Begriff zum einen weil ich keine Suppen
esse zum anderen weil die tatsächlich in
einer Sendung von 2015 waren also eine
der allerersten Staffeln angefragt an
6000 € für 8% bekommen haben sie 150.000
€ für 30% was ein Firmenwert von 500.000
€ macht und das soll sich für die Löwen
und auch für die Gründer als unglaublich
krassen Deal herausstellen denn am Ende
wird das Unternehmen verkauft für wie
viel was die Details sind und warum
erzähle ich euch gleich ähnlich wie auch
schon wi was wir vorher getestet haben
und auch ein paar Produkte die noch
kommen konnten wir das einfach im Rewe
kaufen butet das Ding muss laufen
biosuppen ohne Konservierungsstoffe und
so weiter trotzdem 24 Monate haltbar das
Ding ist Max hat gerade seine eigene
Marke Pasta poesia rausgebracht Link ist
in der Videobeschreibung mit
unglaublicher fertigpasta für zu Hause
in wenigen Schritten selber gemacht und
so weiter check das aus ist unglaublich
und deswegen hängt die Messlatte richtig
hoch aber vielleicht ist der Geschmack
so gut dass er mich überzeugen kann
Kartoffelsuppe biosuppe mit Kartoffeln
und Lauch rote Linsensuppe orientalische
Art mit roten Linsen ja ist
merwegglas gutes
Design Suppe
halt
das riecht bisschen nach Currywurst 3,90
€ pro Portion finde ich für ein Bio
fertig Produkt mehr als fair und die
Dinger verkaufen sich richtig 16
Millionen Euro Jahresumsatz war das
letzte was wir an Zahlen gefunden haben
die Gründer haben tatsächlich das
gesamte Unternehmen an Bio Lebensmittel
Hersteller aus Norddeutschland verkauft
und Stillschweigen darüber bewahrt für
wie viel sie das Unternehmen verkauft
haben aber 16 Millionen Euro jahresumsze
jetzt mal so ganz grob über ein Daumen
gepeilt weiß ich nicht vielleicht
zwischen 30 und 50 Millionen gutes Ding
für die Löwen wenn es jetzt noch
schmeckt aber ich meine bei den großen
Unternehmen sprechen die Zahlen für sich
ne wenn solche Umsätze gemacht werden
dann schmeckt das
Produkt
ja ist gut das ist nicht so mein
Geschmack Linsen eh nicht so mein type
aber eine sehr gute Suppe das hier viel
aussagekräftiger für mich
Kartoffel um ehrlich zu sein etwas slimy
so irgendwas irgendwas glibberiges an
sich was nicht so ganz mein Fall ist
aber fühlt sich so ein bisschen so an
wie als wäder so Speisestärke oder
Soßenbinder oder irgendwie sowas
dran nee nee ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne
das ist es nicht hab gerade noch mal
geschaut das ist tatsächlich Stärke in
dem Produkt was diesen Glibber Glibber
werden lässt hätte es nicht gebraucht
wenn ich auf einer biosuppe das biabel
sehe dann erwarte ich irgendwas was
möglichst unverarbeitet ist das ist
wirklich so dass es mir negativ auffällt
schmeckt wie eine billige Bratensoße mit
Kartoffelgeschmack also vorher kein
suppenfreund gewesen little Lunch hat
mich jetzt auch nicht zum suppenfreund
gemacht die Produkte sind auf dem Papier
wunderbar mein Geschmack ist es nicht
wegen des glibbers und weil Suppe
ist so hart muss ich sein ich bleibe bei
anderen fertigpukten nichtsdestotrotz
super Produkt und mit Recht vermutlich
diese Umsätze und diesen wunderbaren
Verkauf gemacht ein tolles Produkt der
die Höhle der Löwen Fernsehgeschichte
ankerkraut was soll ich euch sagen die
dhdl Erfolgsgeschichte überhaupt ihr
kennt das Produkt super viel influencer
Werbung dann der Verkauf an Nestle mega
der Aufschrei Millionen Millionen
Millionen über den Tisch gegangen für
den Verkauf aber bevor das alles
passiert ist waren 300.000 € angefragt
für 10 % bekommen haben sie 300.000 €
für 20%. auch das hat sich für alle
Parteien ziemlich krass gelohnt am Ende
sind die Produkte allerlei
Gewürzmischung die nach ihren Gerichten
benannt sind also es gibt z.B
omelettegeürz oder spiegeleigewürz oder
Nudel mit pestogewürz keine Ahnung wir
haben hier Bolognese freibadpommes und
rühreimix also am Ende sollen diese
Gewürze es jedem noch so unbegabten Koch
wie auch mir ermöglichen richtig gute
Gerichte zu zaubern das Ding ist richtig
eingeschlagen wir haben unheimlich viel
verkauft sehr viel influencer Werbung
gemacht und sind eine riesenfma geworden
wir haben diese Gewürze in dem ankerk
eigenen Store in der Haupteinkaufsstraße
in Köln gekauft das gibt schon mal so
ein bisschen Dimension in 2016 ca 5
Millionen Euro Umsatz gemacht was schon
ordentlich ist in
2021 lag es dann schon bei 60 Millionen
Euro Umsatz und sie waren selber als
gastjuroren in der zehnten Staffel vonom
dhdl also es hat funktioniert auf allen
Ebenen am Ende und das muss ich
natürlich erwähnen überschattet für
viele aber der mehrheitsverkauf von 95%
an Nestle der Preis des Verkaufs Nestle
wurde stillschweigend behandelt wir
kriegen also keine genauen Daten preis
für die Gewürze 5,99 € muss ich sagen
finde ich komplett fair die Portionen
sind riesig das ist einfach
gut ich lass jetzt Salz Pfeffer und
diesen ganzen anderen Spaß weg weil wenn
das funktioniert ne dann brauche ich nur
das Gewürz hau das rein und wir bekommen
das perfekte Ergebnis so rührein miix
wie viel keine Ahnung ich ma mal so ein
bisschen nach Gefühl und rein damit
[Musik]
ja schmeckt nach Rührei aber ich glaube
ich habe ein bisschen zu wenig dran
gemacht man schmeckt halt nicht viel
ne ist gut gut ein gutes Rührei also ich
muss am Ende sagen gutes Konzept guter
Preis gutes Produkt gutes Design gute
Idee easy zu kaufen in allen Läden
eigenen Stores schlecht dass sie an
Nestle verkauft haben was für eine
Erfolgsgeschichte unser vorletztes
Produkt nennt sich waterdrop und hat
eine unglaubliche Story bei dhdl waren 1
Million für 10% angefragt bekommen haben
Sie 1 Million für 12,5% was ein
Firmenwert von 8 Millionen ergibt das
sollte sich aber relativ schnell ändern
im Grunde ist die Idee daraus entstanden
dass die beiden Gründer im Flugzeug
saßen und sich weder für er noch für ein
super zuckerhaltiges Getränk wie Cola
oder so entscheiden wollten und
irgendwie eine Alternative gesucht haben
entstanden sind diese water drrops
kleine 5 g große Würfel die durch jeden
flaschenhalz passen und aus normalem
Wasser irgendein Wasser mit Geschmack
machen und das in verschiedene
Richtungen Design sieht super aus
Geschmäcker in alle verschiedenen
Richtungen mittlerweile in 3000 Stores
europaweit verfügbar eigene Flagship
Stores in Miami und vielen anderen
Metropolen also das Ding ging richtig ab
2016 750.000 € Umsatz 2017 dann schon 5
Millionen 2020 dann 45 Millionen und
2021 90 Millionen Euro Jahresumsatz 2020
kam dann Novak dukovic mit einer so
heißt es signifikanten siebenstelligen
Summe als Investment mit rein werden 180
Leute weltweit unterstützt irgendwelche
Sportler Teammitglieder was auch immer
und wir schauen jetzt ob das tatsächlich
was bringt hier oben ist eine Lasche
push to open da drücken wir einfach rein
und schieben damit die waterdops hier
nach unten raus die sind wie es aussieht
alle noch mal einzeln in Plastik
eingepackt ist wahrscheinlich auch nötig
weil die Dinger sich eben in Kontakt mit
Wasser auflösen sind die nur im Karton
werden die beim Transport bei der
Lagerung irgendwie nur ein bisschen
feucht lösen die sich auf und dann hat
man nicht 12 water drrops in einer
Packung sondern einen sehr großen der
der dann durch keinen Flaschenhals mehr
passt eine Packung kostet 8,99 bedeutet
auf 12 Portionen die in einer Packung
drin sind 75 Cent pro Stück damit ist
man fast imm Normalbereich ein bisschen
unter ein Normalbereich von dem fertigen
Softdrink den man sich kauft besser
hieran ist die Dinger sind zu
transportieren die schmeißt bei dir
Rucksack hast deine eigene Flasche dabei
und im best case verzichtet man auf
Zucker und hat trotzdem Geschmack ziehen
das Ding auf haen das rein es fängt
direkt an zu sprudeln und löst sich auf
Brombeere
eiste4ig Alter wenn da wirklich kein
Zucker drin ist ist es richtig
krass Eistee Zitrone mindestens genauso
krass Limette grüner Tee etwas mehr
saddle also ein bisschen weniger harter
Geschmack und Nero hier ist sogar
Koffein drin richtig krass würde man mir
das mit verbundenen Augen zeigen würde
ich wahrscheinlich zwischen dem
waterdrop Eistee und dem herkömlichen
zuckereistee keinen richtigen
Unterschied merken und das ist schon
richtig krass Preis finde ich etwas zu
hoch 75 Cent pro waterdrop finde ich ein
bisschen zu viel würde es eher bei 50
Cent liegen dann so 1 € Liter Preis das
wäre perfekt so liegen wir bei 1,50
Liter Preis das ist mir ein bisschen zu
teuer krasses Produkt und verdient
richtig richtig big geworden letzte
Produkt und die mit Abstand krasseste
DDL Geschichte angefragt waren 200.000 €
für 10 % bekommen haben sie 200.000 €
für 20%. Firmenwert damals von
lächerlichen 1 Millionen Euro und dieses
Produkt ist dabei rausgekommen
mittlerweile in unheimlich vielen
verschiedenen gesmacksrichtungen abseits
von all dem Kram auf den ich gleich noch
mal eingehe muss ich sagen ich liebe wi
nichts bezahlt ich bin nicht mehr mit
denen verpartnert ich habe seit einem
Jahr keine Werbung für die gemacht trink
mal Zeiten für mich aber ein absolutes
mega Produkt die stehen in der Kritik
weil sie sagen kein Zucker und dann ist
aber doch irgend zuckerersatzprodukt
drin dann wurden die Inhaltsstoffe
aufgedeckt das ist alles nicht so gut
wie von ihnen gesagt die haben an Nestle
verkauft am Ende wenn es nur um das
Produkt geht muss ich aber sagen ich
liebe wfood und ich kaufe es und trinke
es und ich muss mir hier mal kurz mein
Laptop zur Hand nehmen um euch die
Geschichte einmal zu erzählen 2017
Gründung 2018 Ausstrahlung bei dhdl
Frank Thelen investiert und im selben
Jahr kommen noch 21 Millionen von
irgendwelchen anderen VCS und Investoren
ins Unternehmen rein 2021 dann 60
Millionen Umsatz 2022 120 Millionen Euro
Umsatz 2023 es bleibt offen was klar ist
sie expandieren und das international
ich Werbung bei internationalen
Youtubern mittlerweile ist wfood in
unheimlich vielen Ländern verfügbar wir
testen es jetzt noch mal Alibi mäßig
aber ich kenne es ja mein
Lieblingsgeschmack Schoko es wirkt als
würde ich dafür bezahlt werden aber ihr
könnt euch nicht vorstellen ich habe das
literweise gesoffen über die letzten
Jahre ich finde das Produkt wirklich
einfach richtig gut und das will ich
einmal ganz klar sagen auf Ernährung zu
achten ist nicht besonders schwierig ein
Schluck hiervon und du weißt dass das
nicht 100% natürlich sein kann und dass
hier definitiv Zucker drin ist und wenn
es kein Zucker ist dann ist es trylose
oder Zucker dritten Grades oder keine
Ahnung wie man das nennt falsche
Werbeversprechen sind falsch sollten auf
gar keinen Fall passieren achtet selber
drauf was ihr trinkt was ihr esst lasst
euch nicht von irgendwelchen
Aufschriften oder so an der Nase
rumführen ja meine Damen und Herren das
war die zehnte und letzte Folge von ich
teste dhdl Produkte uns gehen die
Produkte aus es geht nicht mehr weiter
es war eine wunderbare Zeit vielen Dank
für euer ganzes Feedback euren Support
Millionen von views auf diese Serie
vielleicht sehen wir uns irgendwann zu
einer Staffel 2 wieder wenn es neue
Produkte gibt die wir unter die Lupe
nehmen können bis dahin macht es gut auf
nimmer
wiedersehen